bétonner surpeuplés et bruyante la ville
de Paris et la vision que l'on s'en fait
semble à milieu de la notion même de vie
sauvage les scientifiques comme les
autorités multiplient pourtant les
études depuis les années 2000
contrairement aux idées reçues la nature
parisienne foisonnerait à l'abri des
regards ce pourrait-il qu'elle soit plus
résistante qu'attendue malgré les
pollutions sonores et visuelles générées
par les activités humaines en bref
existe-t-il toujours de la vie sauvage à
Paris c'est ce que nous vous proposons
de voir dans ce nouvel épisode de
facture
[Applaudissements]
selon l'Atlas de la nature 2020 la
capitale est un véritable réservoir de
biodiversité la flore parisienne
compterait 831 espèces comme des
Merisiers des Sophoras du Japon ou du
sureau noir la faune y est très présente
puisque 1618 espèces six côtes des
renards roux des orvets et même des
flocons pèlerins enfin 1132 espèces
d'insectes formeraient la base de cet
écosystème urbain pour comprendre
comment il est important d'étudier
l'histoire et la géographie parisienne
la ville de Paris a une densité de
population bien supérieure à celle de
ses voisines d'Europe dans la capitale
française il y a 20360 habitants au
kilomètre carré contre 5667 habitants au
kilomètre carré à Londres et 42003
habitants en kilomètres carrés à Berlin
c'est donc une concentration importante
d'humains mais aussi de transport de
route et de béton en bref la nature s'y
trouve à l'étroit
la capitale a d'ailleurs attendu
longtemps avant de se mettre au vert ce
n'est qu'à partir des années 1730 que la
ville au travers de grands travaux se
dote d'espaces verts d'agrément comme
des parcs jardins et cimetière paysagers
les espaces cultivés sont menés
courantes et sont très utiles pour de
nombreuses espèces de plantes et
d'insectes selon un document de
l'atelier parisien d'urbanisme
détaillant l'évolution de la nature à
Paris de 1730 à nos jours ce que l'on
appelle la surface de nature à fortement
évolué elle passe de 18,56% à l'époque à
27,40% aujourd'hui un tour de force
lorsqu'on sait qu'entre ces deux dates
la surface de Paris a été multipliée par
près de 10 l'histoire de la nature dans
la ville et l'histoire de nature dans
Paris c'est une histoire d'amour haine
au départ un rejet on veut que la nature
elle soit loin le plus loin possible
parce que la nature ça veut dire des
maladies c'est dangereux on va partir de
d'une époque où il y aura plus un arbre
à Paris il y a que de que de la pierre
et ça on va se que c'est pas bon pour
notre santé en fait et aujourd'hui on
tous les projets nouveaux intègrent la
nature donc je crois que si on passe les
siècles on se rend compte qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'animaux quand même
aujourd'hui il y en a plus que 16e
siècle à mon avis la ville s'est donné
les moyens au fil des ans d'augmenter la
part de ses espaces verts pour autant
cela ne signifie pas un renouveau de la
biodiversité parisienne ces espaces sont
faits pour les humains ils ont été créés
dans un but social productiviste non
écologique à titre d'exemple la part des
zones maraîchères pourtant essentielle à
la vie sauvage s'effondre à partir de
1900 au début des années 2000 les
publications scientifiques sur la vie
sauvage se multiplient elles attestent
de la présence renouvelée d'animaux dans
la ville cela peut s'expliquer par trois
facteurs tout d'abord les fruits
industrielles sont reconquises et
aménagées à partir des années 1980 parc
des jardins se multiplient dans la
capitale plus de 200 d'entre eux voient
le jour entre 1975 et aujourd'hui
deuxièmement l'interdiction de
l'utilisation des pesticides dans les
parcs et jardins annoncés dès 200 6 mais
mis en pratique en 2017 elle permet à de
nombreux insectes de revenir habiter les
espaces de nature puisqu'ils forment la
base de la chaîne alimentaire ils
attirent des prédateurs et la
biodiversité s'étoffe
enfin la problématique écologique prend
de l'ampleur à partir des années 1970
elle se concrétise par un plus grand
respect de la nature et par la
multiplication des espaces de culture et
de végétalisation entretenues par les
citoyens eux-mêmes tous ces changements
récents vont avoir pour effet de créer
des trames vertes et bleu un réseau de
continuité écologique terrestre et
aquatique qui s'étale sur toute la
capitale les animaux peuvent alors vivre
nicher et se reproduire en sécurité dans
ce que l'on appelle les réservoirs de
biodiversité comme le bois de Vincennes
ou le bois de Boulogne par exemple ils
peuvent également se déplacer au travers
de l'agglomération via des corridors
écologiques comme la Seine ou les
alignements d'arbres beaucoup d'espèces
européens mais en France on a une seule
espèce de renard donc le renard roux
dans les grands dans les grands parcs
parisiens dans le dans les cimetières
dans les zones désinfectées comme la
Petite Ceinture les chauves-souris qu'on
trouve en ville la pipistrelle commune
c'est vraiment l'espèce la plus
abondante en ville dans certains tunnels
désaffectés de la Petite Ceinture on a
trouvé au milieu des années 90 les plus
gros les plus gros sites d'hibernation
connu de pipistrelle en ville
sur la planète beaucoup d'anguille dans
la Seine par exemple ça c'est assez
rigolo les anguilles il faut quand même
se rappeler que elles sont toutes nées
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique dans la
mer des Sargasses on en trouve dans
Paris donc elle nous raconte une
histoire une guêpe très spécialisée
qu'on trouve assez finalement pas très
rarement Paris qui s'appelle la filante
à pivor le loup des abeilles moyen un
truc qui m'avait un petit peu étonné
parce que j'ai remarqué plusieurs fois
dans Paris c'est la présence du mulot
sylvestre c'est vraiment le rongeur des
forêts des milieux ruraux il est présent
dans la plupart des parcs parisiens et
pourtant les habitants de Paris n'ont
pas forcément l'impression d'être
entouré de nature mais alors pourquoi
a-t-on jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'impression
que la vie sauvage est inexistante à
Paris vie sauvage dans Paris la vie
sauvage auprès de l'homme elle a jamais
cessé d'être là et simplement notre
regard a changé on y prête beaucoup plus
attention parce que il y a de l'empathie
qui a généré vers le monde sauvage et
donc on voit des choses qu'on ne
regardait pas par le passé parce que par
le passé
regardez la nature c'était regarder ce
qui était naturel ce qui était naturel
c'était là où il y avait pas d'homme et
donc on faisait plutôt des randonnées
pour aller donc les premières lignes de
train qu'elle a sur Fontainebleau des
choses comme ça c'est plus le cas
maintenant en fait où il y a des il y a
des il y a des amateurs naturalistes qui
passent leur temps à regarder la nature
en ville
[Musique]